La mitad de toda la población de Siria son ahora refugiados,
en su mayoría, provenientes del interior del país.
Seis millones y medio de personas han huido para salvar sus vidas.
Muchos más de 3 millones de personas
han cruzado las fronteras
para encontrar asilo en los países vecinos
y solo una pequeña proporción, como ven,
se trasladó a Europa.
Creo que lo más preocupante
es que la mitad de los refugiados sirios sean niños.
Le hice la foto a esta niña 2 horas después de su llegada,
después de un largo viaje que hizo de Siria a Jordania.
Y lo más preocupante de todo esto
es que solo el 20 % de los niños refugiados sirios
irán a la escuela en el Líbano.
Aún así, los niños refugiados sirios,
todos los niños refugiados nos dicen
que la educación es lo más importante en sus vidas.
¿Por qué?
Porque les permite pensar en el futuro
en lugar de pensar en las pesadillas de su pasado.
Les permite pensar en algo esperanzador en lugar de recordar el odio.
Recuerdo que hice una visita reciente
a un campo de refugiados sirios al norte de Irak,
y conocí a esta chica y pensé: "¡Qué hermosa!",
y le pedí permiso para hacerle una foto
y ella dijo que sí pero se negó a sonreír.
Creo que no podía hacerlo
porque creo que era consciente
de que es parte de esta generación perdida de niños refugiados sirios,
una generación aislada y frustrada.
Sin embargo, miren de lo que huyeron:
la destrucción total de los edificios,
industrias, escuelas, carreteras, viviendas.
La casa de Hany también fue destruida.
Todo esto tendrá que ser reconstruido
por arquitectos, ingenieros, electricistas.
Las comunidades necesitarán maestros, abogados
y políticos interesados en la reconciliación y no en la venganza.
¿No debería esto ser reconstruido
por las personas que más han tenido que perder,
los que están en el exilio, los refugiados?
Los refugiados tienen mucho tiempo para prepararse para su regreso.
Es posible que crean que ser refugiado es solo algo temporal.
Nada de eso.
Con las guerras que no cesan,
el tiempo medio de un refugiado en el exilio es de 17 años.
Hany estaba en su segundo año en el limbo
cuando fui a verlo recientemente.
Nuestra conversación fue toda en inglés,
ya que confesó haber aprendido el idioma
leyendo las novelas de Dan Brown y escuchando rap de EE.UU.
También pasamos unos momentos de risas y diversión
con su querido hermano, Ashraf.
Pero nunca olvidaré lo que me dijo cuando terminamos la conversación ese día:
"Si no estudio, no seré nada".
Hany es uno de las 50 millones de personas refugiadas en el mundo hoy en día.
Nunca, desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
tantas personas se vieron obligadas a exiliarse.
Así que, mientras hacemos enormes progresos
en la salud humana, la tecnología, la educación y el diseño,
hacemos peligrosamente poco para ayudar a las víctimas,
y estamos haciendo aún menos
para detener y prevenir las guerras que los expulsan de sus hogares.
Y hay cada vez más víctimas.
Diariamente al final del día, de media,
32 000 personas estarán desplazadas de sus hogares por la fuerza.
32 000 personas.
Que tienen que tienen que huir pasando fronteras como esta.
Rodamos esto en la frontera de Siria con Jordania
y esto está a la orden del día.
O huyen en embarcaciones improvisadas, sobrecargadas,
arriesgando la vida, en este caso,
solo para alcanzar un lugar más seguro en Europa.
Este joven sirio sobrevivió
a uno de estos barcos que volcaron y donde se ahogó la mayoría de la gente.
Nos dijo: Los sirios estamos solo buscando un lugar tranquilo
donde nadie nos haga daño,
donde nadie nos humille y donde nadie nos mate".
Y creo que lo que pide es lo mínimo.
¿Qué tal un lugar donde curarse,
aprender e incluso tener oportunidades?
Los estadounidenses y los europeos tienen la impresión
de que el grueso de refugiados son los que llegan a sus países,
pero la realidad es que el 86 %, la gran mayoría de los refugiados,
vive en países en desarrollo,
en países que luchan con sus propias inseguridades,
con sus propios problemas para ayudar a su propio pueblo
y que luchan contra la pobreza.
Así que los países ricos del mundo deberían reconocer
la humanidad y generosidad de los países que acogen a tantos refugiados.
Y todos los países deben asegurarse
de que nadie que huye de la guerra y de la persecución
llegue a una frontera cerrada.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Pero hay algo que podemos hacer
más allá de simplemente ayudar a los refugiados a sobrevivir.
Podemos ayudarles a prosperar.
Debemos pensar en campamentos y comunidades de refugiados
como en algo más que centros de población temporal,
donde la gente sufre y perece esperando el final de la guerra.
Más bien como centros de excelencia,
donde los refugiados puedan superar el trauma
y ser formados para el día en que puedan regresar a casa
como agentes de cambio positivo y de transformación social.
Esto tiene mucho más sentido,
pero recuerdo la terrible guerra en Somalia
que se ha estado librando durante 22 años.
E imaginen vivir en este campo.
Yo lo visité.
Es en Djibouti, en la frontera con Somalia, y estaba tan lejos,
que nos hizo falta un helicóptero para llegar allí.
Hacía mucho calor y todo estaba lleno de polvo.
Nos fuimos a visitar una escuela y empezamos a hablar con los niños.
Entonces vi a esta chica al fondo de la habitación,
parecía tener la misma edad que mi hija y fui a hablar con ella.
Le hice preguntas del tipo de las que hacen los adultos a los niños:
¿Cuál es tu asignatura favorita?
¿Qué quieres ser cuando seas mayor?
Y fue entonces cuando su rostro se convirtió en una máscara y dijo:
"Yo no tengo futuro. Mi formación se acabó".
Y pensé, tiene que haber algún error, así que me dirigí a mi colega
pero ella me confirmó que no hay fondos para la escuela secundaria en este campo.
Cómo me hubiera gustado decirle, en ese momento:
"Vamos a construir una escuela para ti".
Y también pensé, qué desperdicio.
Ella debe ser y es el futuro de Somalia.
A otro niño, llamado Jacob Atem, se le brindó una oportunidad diferente,
pero no antes de sufrir una terrible tragedia.
Fue testigo --esto pasó en Sudán--
de cómo su pueblo --y él tenía solo 7 años--
fue quemado hasta la médula,
para luego descubrir que su madre y su padre y toda su familia
fueron asesinados ese día.
solo sobrevivió su primo, y ambos caminaron durante 7 meses
--estos son chicos como él--
cazados y perseguidos por los animales salvajes y las bandas armadas,
hasta que finalmente llegaron a un campo de refugiados
donde encontraron seguridad.
Pasó los siguientes 7 años en Kenia, en un campo de refugiados,
pero su vida cambió
cuando tuvo la oportunidad de vivir en EE.UU.
al encontrar el amor de una familia de acogida,
y así poder ir a la escuela.
Me pidió que compartiera con Uds. este momento de orgullo,
cuando se graduó en la universidad.
(Aplausos)
Hablé con él por Skype, el otro día,
está estudiando en una universidad en Florida
un doctorado en salud pública.
Me dijo lleno de orgullo
que pudo recaudar fondos con la ayuda del pueblo estadounidense
para una clínica en su aldea, en su tierra natal.
Quiero volver a Hany.
Cuando le dije que iba a hablar aquí en TED,
me permitió leer un poema que me envió por correo electrónico.
Dice:
"Me echo de menos,
y añoro a mis amigos
y aquellos ratos en que leía novelas y escribía poemas,
mirando los pájaros por la mañana y tomando el té.
Echo de menos a mi cuarto, mis libros, me echo de menos,
a mí y a todo aquello que me hacía sonreír.
Oh, tenía tantos sueños
que iban a hacerse realidad".
Así que, este es mi mensaje.
No invertir en refugiados es perder una enorme oportunidad.
Si los abandonamos
correrán el riesgo de ser explotados y de sufrir abusos,
si no les ofrecemos una cualificación y educación,
perderemos años y retrasaremos el proceso de paz y la prosperidad en sus países.
Yo creo que la forma en que tratamos a los refugiados
contribuye al futuro de nuestro mundo.
Las víctimas de la guerra pueden ser la clave de una paz duradera
y los refugiados son los que pueden detener el ciclo de la violencia.
Hany se encuentra en un momento crítico.
Nos encantaría ayudarle a llegar a la universidad
y convertirse en ingeniero,
pero nuestros fondos dan prioridad a las necesidades básicas de la vida:
tiendas de campaña, mantas y utensilios de cocina,
alimentos racionados y algunas medicinas.
La universidad es un lujo.
Pero abandonarlo a la vera de un pantano
es dejarlo convertirse en un miembro más de una generación perdida.
La historia de Hany es una tragedia,
pero no tiene por qué terminar así.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)